are you already planting the seeds for
the next crossover event for if it's
Secret Wars or what like the space for
start to plant the seeds for whatever
we're gonna see because we obviously saw
Thanos the whole infinity saga the seeds
were planted way early on yes we debated
what we should announce today should we
announce four and five we've planned
them out we've got five years down the
road and I was like I think you got 11
projects in two years is plenty having
not mentioned anything for - two or
three years everybody it's Charlie you
guys may remember around comic-con there
were rumors about a bunch of secret
projects that Marvel was developing but
did not announce during their comic-con
panel so as Kevin Feige says during that
clip there's a lot of stuff that we're
building up towards our next Avengers
movie we're laying the seeds you will
see all that happen during Marvel phase
four well here's the thing right around
comic-con a bunch of internet super
sleuths found a bunch of secret movie
pages that Marvel created and they only
announced what a couple of those were at
the comic-con panel meaning that we just
found out about a whole bunch of secret
projects that they're developing for
Marvel phase 5 and beyond so we'll break
it all down we're doing the Avengers end
game and spider-man far from home
blu-ray giveaways all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
your best Marvel phase 5 theory on the
video the Marvel Comic Con panel was all
about announcing their Marvel phase 4
slate between the movies the TV shows
then a couple things on top of that like
the Fantastic Four movie the x-men movie
that they're working on he talked about
mutants that really means their Deadpool
movies - x-men and Deadpool movies but
also the Blade movie
[Applause]
there's no time lapse to talk about a
mutant they also didn't say anything
about spider-man 3 because technically
that's sony's right to announce that
movie so later this year Sony's gonna be
making a bunch of big announcements
about venom 2 spider-man 3 and all the
live-action spider-man TV shows that
they're developing as he said during
that clip at the beginning of this Kevin
bye he's like we felt like all the stuff
we announced all those projects was
enough for now but we know what the next
5 years solid are meaning that he has
pretty much all of Marvel phase 5
planned phase 5 could last a little bit
longer than that because I don't know
necessarily that he's officially got a
date for the Fantastic Four movie or the
next x-men movie but we know that'll be
happening sometime during Marvel phase 5
we know about black panther 2 we know
about the Captain Marvel sequel we know
about guardians of the galaxy vol 3 so
there's already a bunch of Marvel phase
5 stuff that we know is happening but
marble created eight new landing pages
for movies on Facebook only announced
what two of those are publicly including
the black widow movie in a page for what
they're calling Marvel's eternals
because a lot of people on facebook
probably have no ideas what the Eternals
are so they put Marvel in front of it to
let them know that it's part of the
Marvel Universe that means that there
are six other secret Marvel phase 5
movies or potential TV shows they're
developing right now some of these are
fan favorites that probably make you go
crazy and some of them we've already
heard Kevin Feige talk about during
interviews so I'll talk about these in
descending order of hype from just
regular hype to maximum hype number six
there's a secret page for an iron heart
movie or Disney plus TV show iron heart
kind of feels more like a miniseries
there are a lot of people wondering that
they change the comics and make sure II
iron heart in the MCU after the Black
Panther movie blew up so big in latisha
Wright stole all the scenes that she was
in as Sheree did he freeze like an
antelope in headlights are you finished
I'm not expecting them to make Sheree
iron heart but I would be fine with them
giving her an iron heart Disney Plus
miniseries as long as they let some big
science bro Marvel characters crossover
like The Hulk spider-man maybe some
Young Avengers characters speaking of
Young Avengers number five one of the
secret movie pages Marvel created is for
young of
dangers just based on the characters
they already have introduced as of
Avengers endgame in the new stuff that
they've announced during Marvel phase 4
they already almost have half a Young
Avengers squad you have Cassie Lang
whose stature in the comics you have
harley keener from Iron Man 3 was a
teenager now he could become their iron
lad if they don't want Shuri to become
Iron Heart people were actually asking
him in real life would you want to come
back to do a young Avengers movie he's
like hell yes I would love to come back
and play iron lad in the Marvel movies
we know we're getting Kate Bishop in the
Hawkeye series and even though Helen Cho
from Avengers age of Ultron isn't quite
old enough for us to say that Amadeus
Cho could be her son she could have a
nephew or a cousin that's named Amadeus
Cho who's the right age to join a young
Avengers team that's if they don't want
to do Howe chling in the comics the
original sort of Hulk character on young
Avengers was called ho chling but he's
not necessarily another version of the
Hulk he's just a shapeshifter that can
mimic the look of the Hulk he doesn't
have the same gamma powers like Amadeus
Cho eventually gets in the comics when
he absorbs banners gamma there's a whole
bunch of even bigger characters they
could put on a young Avengers team but
given that they started the original
Avengers team with six members I'd
assume that they'd shoot for six Young
Avengers characters and cameos from any
of the surviving original Avengers to
serve as mentors to them like Hulk
Hawkeye maybe even some of the newer
ones who are more akin to time-travel
characters like dr. strange because
Young Avengers is kind of a time-travel
franchise in the comics so think of Kang
the Conqueror as a really good young
avengers villain number four secret
movie is Moon Knight there have been so
many discussions about what they're
gonna do with Moon Knight in the MCU is
it gonna be a TV show is gonna be a
movie it would be great as a really dark
miniseries but they would have to put it
on Hulu because the darker stuff isn't
going to Disney Plus like Deadpool all
the r-rated stuff is going to Hulu
instead of that because Disney Plus is
meant to be more pg-13 content but that
doesn't mean that Marvel won't do a moon
night TV series it would be amazing
either way if you're not familiar with
that comic book character moon night is
kind of like a schizophrenic version of
Batman he's clinically diagnosed as
opposed to Batman who people just say
you're crazy Batman for doing all the
things that you do since
fan casting Keanu Reeves is every major
Marvel character that's coming in the
next ten years I will say Keanu Reeves
would be a fantastic Moon Knight
number three is a not-so-secret Marvel
x-men movie no big surprise here Kevin
Feige already said as much during the
comic-con panel no official release date
yet but sometime during Marvel phase
five probably tale and Marvel phase five
because you probably just heard Disney
took a giant right down on the loss they
took from x-men Dark Phoenix they are
pissed about that so they're just gonna
let that marinate for a little while
till the public largely forgets that
that movie ever happened so don't expect
a Marvel x-men film for at least four or
five years the secret movie page they
created for it is just called Marvel's
x-men so it sounds like they're not just
gonna take over the page that Fox
created for the Bryan Singer films like
they're just kind of wiping the slate
clean we're gonna start fresh with
Marvel's x-men they've said nothing
about what the reboot of the characters
is gonna look like or what the first
roster is going to be foggy only said
that it was an opportunity to do a
version of the x-men that you've never
seen before so it sounds like it won't
be as simple as them just redoing the
exact same roster from the Bryan Singer
x-men films assume that everyone besides
Deadpool is gonna be recast Ryan
Reynolds is the only person who's safe
from that lot at Fox if they didn't
create a secret Marvel Deadpool movie
page because it sounds like they're just
taking over the Ryan Reynolds Deadpool
movie page number two hitting the really
big ones here there's a secret page for
a Dark Avengers movie there's been talk
about versions of Dark Avengers scripts
floating around it sounds like they've
been thinking about doing that movie for
a while you can't do a Dark Avengers
movie without Norman Osborn so it feels
like they have to introduce a version of
him at some point in the next three to
four years between the spider-man movies
and Avengers 5 and just because they're
working on a secret Dark Avengers movie
doesn't automatically mean that Avengers
5 is gonna be Dark Avengers but if they
develop enough good villains between now
and then and don't kill them off I would
love to see a Thunderbolts project spin
up into a Dark Avengers movie
interestingly enough though Marvel did
not create a secret page for
Thunderbolts but that doesn't mean that
they're not thinking about doing a
thunderbolt series in number one maximum
hype here they created a secret movie
page
for an Avengers vs. x-men project now I
think we can all agree this feels like
something that we wouldn't see for six
or seven years it's gonna take a long
time to first introduce the x-men then
introduce the concept of Avengers
fighting x-men like you can't do Captain
America Civil War before you do a couple
of those other Avengers films so x-men
vs. Avengers is something that they have
to build up to after they reintroduce
x-men into the MCU I would also be
really cool if they want to do a six to
eight hour miniseries because if you're
talking about Avengers vs. x-men from
the comics that was a huge series and it
would feel weird to try and condense
that down into two and a half hours but
either way it would be fantastic it'd
just be a much much bigger version of
what Captain America Civil War was the
axis comic book storyline was super
crazy involved a big Scarlet Witch twist
everyone gets their alignment flipped so
you have good characters turning evil
and evil characters turning good I think
we can all agree that the movie version
of that would be vastly simplified and
it would be more like Captain America
Civil War part two with them just legit
fighting each other over an issue that
divides them but think about it this way
eventually we're gonna see a version of
the MCU where you have a new Avengers
roster with probably a couple x-men
characters on the team a full Fantastic
Four or future foundation squad an
all-new x-men team and a young Avengers
team each of those separate teams is
strong enough to carry their own
franchise and Disney Marvel are all
about maximizing franchise potential why
try to cram all those characters into
Avengers movies with a billion sequels
when you can make four or five separate
team based franchises that separately
get a bunch of sequels themselves but
that's all way way down the road we're
talking way beyond Marvel phase 5
but post all your Marvel phase 5
theories in the comments which of these
movies do you want to see the most
assuming Avengers vs. x-men play isn't
gonna happen for a long long time I'm
working on a new Fantastic Four video in
a Eternals video and then the big Marvel
d23 panel is coming in a couple weeks
they'll pie show off some footage from
the Marvel phase 4 movies at that I'll
name a giveaway winner when I post my
next Marvel video everybody click here
for that scene with a black panther to
name more Easter eggs and click here to
learn about the Red Hulk deleted scene
from Avenger
M game thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]